>> 3 - 2, GAME 6 IN BOSTON
TODAY.
WARRIORS, BOSTON, I DON'T KNOW
WHICH WAY TO GO.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY TO LEAN,
SO WHEN I DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY
TO LEAN OR GO, USUALLY YOU GUYS
ALREADY KNOW, I'M ALWAYS
ROCKING WITH MY WARRIORS SO
THIS MIGHT MEAN SOMETHING.
YOU GUYS MIGHT BE ABLE TO TAKE
SOMETHING FROM THIS, TAKE AN
ANGLE FROM IT, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH WAY TO GO
BUT I KNOW WHEN I DON'T KNOW
WHICH WAY TO GO I KNOW WHERE TO
GO AND THAT'S WITH SAM
RICHMOND.
LET ME BRING HIM IN.
WHAT'S HAPPENING, BROTHER?
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
>> I FEEL GREAT, MAN.
I ALSO LOVE THAT YOU ARE
PLAYING THIS I DON'T KNOW WHAT
TO BET.
YOU'RE GOING TO BET THE
WARRIORS.
BUT I LOVE THAT YOU ARE TRYING
TO TEASE THE AUDIENCE.
>> I'M JUST BEING HONEST, I'M
BEING HONEST TODAY.
I REALLY DO NOT KNOW WHICH WAY
TO GO.
SAM, MY HEART SAYS THE
WARRIORS, MY MIND SAYS OF THE
WARRIORS, BUT GAME 6, IN
BOSTON, I FEEL LIKE THE NBA
WANTS 7. I KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR THE MBA IF THEY GET SEVEN,
SO THAT'S HOW I'M THINKING, SAM
. I'M TRYING TO THINK SMART
HERE.
>> I LOVE THAT.
CAN I START GETTING MY PICKS?
CAN I DIVE RIGHT INTO IT?
>> GO AHEAD.
STARTED OFF.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FIRST PICK.
I'M WITH YOU, GREG.
CELTICS -3 1/2.
HOPEFULLY PEOPLE CAN SEE IT, I
GOT VERY BAD INTERNET.
HOPEFULLY THAT IS GOING THROUGH.
WE ARE GOING TO END ON A GOOD
NOTE.
IT MIGHT TAKE A WHILE LIKE I
SAID LAST WEEK THIS WEEK I MEAN
IT, WE ARE GOING TO END ON A
REALLY GOOD NOTE.
>> I LIKE THE CELTICS TONIGHT.
I LIKE HOW YOU TALK ABOUT
ANGLES HERE'S MY A■NGLE TODAY.
THE WARRIORS HAVE BEEN IN THIS
POSITION THE FAST PAST FEW
SERIES WHERE THEY'VE HAD A
CHANCE TO CLOSE OUT A SERIES ON
A ROAD WITH ANOTHER GAME AT
HOME WAITING FOR THEM ON THE
BACK BURNER, AND EVERY TIME
THEY'VE HAD THAT, THEY HAVE
LOST THIS GAME INCLUDING LOSING
BY 50 TO MEMPHIS.
THEY LOST TO DENVER, THEY
DIDN'T CLOSE OUT THE MAVERICKS,
THEY LIKE TO CLOSE OUT A SERIES
AT HOME.
I THINK THEY KNOW THAT, I THINK
THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE ABOUT
HAVING A GAME 7 AND I LIKE THAT
THE CELTICS HAVE NOT LOST THREE
GAMES IN A ROW SINCE LIKE
DECEMBER.
>> SAM, I'M SO SORRY.
DO NOT GIVE ME THAT.
BECAUSE AT FIRST IT WAS, THE
CELTICS DON'T LOSE BACK TO
BACK, THAT HAPPEN.
NOW IT'S LIKE, THEY DON'T LOSE-
- COME ON MAN.
WHAT ELSE?
ARE THE CELTICS NOT GOING TO
LOSE CHAMPIONSHIPS?
CELTICS FANS ARE COMING UP WITH
EVERY STATISTIC, EVERY FORMULA
TO TRY TO COME UP WITH A WAY TO
COME UP WITH THE CELTICS TO WIN.
DON'T GIVE ME THAT.
>> YOU ARE NOT WRONG.
I WAS GOING TO SAY EVERY SINGLE
CELTICS FAN SAID THE SAME THING
FOR GAME FIVE.
LOOK, WE CAN GO IN A DIFFERENT
DIRECTION HERE.
I'VE ALWAYS SAID I THINK THE
CELTICS ARE THE BETTER TEAM.
I'M NEARING PULLING BACK FROM
THAT TAKE AND I CAN GO ON A
LONG RANT ABOUT HOW
DISAPPOINTED I'VE BEEN THE LAST
FEW GAMES BUT MAYBE I WILL SAVE
THAT FOR LATER BUT I'M WITH
YOU.
THEY'VE BEEN A VERY RESILIENT
TEAM AND I THINK THE WARRIORS
AGAIN, WHEN THEY HAVE THAT
CLOSE OUT GAME BACK AT HOME THE
KIND OF LET GO A LITTLE BIT.
SO WE ARE GOING CELTICS -3 1/2
FOR THE FIRST PICK.
>> BET TWO.
>> SECOND.
UNDER 210.
WHICH IF YOU WILL REMEMBER--
>> SAM IS ROCKING WITH THE
UNDER.
THE CELTICS HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO HIT THE 100 MARK
THE LAST COUPLE OF GAMES.
>> IT ALSO LOOKS LIKE MY
INTERNET IS PICKING UP WHICH IS
GREAT, THAT'S GREAT VIBES.
BUT I LIKE UNDER 210 TODAY.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW RARE
THINGS I GOT CORRECT ON, THAT I
THOUGHT ONCE THE SERIES GOT
UNDER, LONGER, YOU WOULD START
TO SEE THE UNDER CASHMORE AND
WE ARE SEEING THAT.
IF STEPH CURRY IS GOING 0 FOR 9,
GAME SIX AND GAME SEVEN THIS IS
THE POINT WHERE IT IS ALL OUT
DEFENSE, EVERY SINGLE
POSSESSION, AND I THINK THE
CELTICS OFFENSE IS LOOKING A
LITTLE MURKY RIGHT NOW, THE
WARRIORS ON THE ROAD, BETTER AT
HOME, SO I LIKE THE UNDER AND I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THOSE
SUPER AGGRESSIVE GAMES AND I
THINK THE UNDER CACHES TONIGHT.
>> I'M IN THE COMMENTS AND I
THINK THIS PLAY AS WELL FOR
WHAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
MY MAN SAYS REPS ARE COMING TO
PLAY TONIGHT.
YOU THINK THE REFEREES ARE
GOING TO HAVE AN ANGLE IN THIS
ONE?
YOU THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
PLAY A PART IN THIS ONE?
>> FIRST SAM'S INTERNET IS THE
FUNNIEST GAG EVER.
I LIKE THAT SOMEONE THINKS THIS
IS A BIT AND NOT THAT I HAVE
AWFUL INTERNET.
NO SCOTT FOSTER TONIGHT.
EVERYONE WAS LOOKING FOR THE
EXTENDER. I JUST THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY PHYSICAL GAME
.
>> MAX SAYS SAM IS SPENDING HIS
INTERNET BUDGET ON CELTICS
MINISTRY IN THE HALF.
THAT'S PROBABLY WHY YOUR
INTERNET IS WHAT IT IS, BECAUSE
YOU ARE PUTTING YOUR INTERNET
BILL MONEY ON THESE THAT'S THAT
I DON'T NECESSARILY AGREE WITH
BUT THAT IS OKAY.
IT'S MOVE ON TO BET NUMBER
THREE, SAM.
YOU GAVE US TWO, WE NEED THE
THIRD ONE.
>> YES.
LET'S TALK AFTER THE SHOW
BECAUSE I NEED YOU TO HELP ME
PULL SOME STRINGS.
I DON'T HAVE THE JUICE LIKE
THAT SO I NEED SOME HELP.
BUT THIS IS GOING TO BE A
LITTLE CONTROVERSIAL AND I
WROTE IT INCORRECTLY MYSELF AND
SAID I COULD GET A NEW PIECE OF
PAPER AND REWRITE IT AND THEN
SAID NO I'M GOING TO BE LAZY
AND CROSS IT OUT AND REWRITE
IT.
WE ARE GOING DRAYMOND GREEN
OVER .5 THREES TONIGHT.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW ME
WIPING MY EYES, BUT BRING THAT
UP ONE MORE TIME BROTHER?
BECAUSE I HAVE TO SEE THAT
CLEARLY.
>> I DROPPED A PIECE OF PAPER
SO I HAVE TO GRAB IT AGAIN.
>> SO HE'S GOING TO WIN A THREE?
I LIKE THAT.
HE IS DUE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT HE DID TO
ME.
I PARLAYED DRAYMOND, THIS IS
GAME FOUR , THE WARRIORS MONEY
LINE +  MONEY TO GET EIGHT
POINTS.
MY MAN ONLY HAD TWO, SO I'M
PRAYING AND SENDING YOU GOOD
VIBES THAT YOU PUT THIS ON
DRAYMOND, HE CAN CASH FOR YOU.
HE LET ME DOWN.
>> HERE'S THE THING.
IT IS +200 AND I THINK HE HAS
HIT TWO THREES THIS ENTIRE
POSTSEASON AND IS 2 FOR LIKE 25
OR 30.
NO DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
BUT HE IS STILL GETTING THE
SHOTS UP. I THINK HE TOOK TWO
LAST GAME, A LOT OF GAMES WERE
THREE, HE'S GETTING THEM UP AND
MAYBE HE'S UNSURE RIGHT NOW BUT
FOR HIS CAREER AND THE SEASON
HE'S ABOUT 25, 30%.
YOU GIVE ME TO CHANCES AT 25 OR
30% + ONE OF THEM TO GO IN AT
+200 IT'S HONESTLY PRETTY GOOD
AND I FEEL LIKE THE KIND OF
NUMBER THAT IT IS NOW BETTABLE
WHERE PEOPLE ARE SO DOWN ON HIM
SO +200, PRETTY INTRIGUING.
>> ONE THING WE KNOW IS THAT
HE'S GOING TO PUT UP A SHOT OR
TWO.
IT'S JUST UP TO THE VIBES,
WHATEVER IT IS IN THE
ATMOSPHERE THAT DAY OR THAT
MOMENT, IT NEEDS TO ALL ONLINE
AND CLICK AND GO IN FOR YOU TO
CASH THAT DRAYMOND GREEN OVER
THREE POINTS BAT.
THAT'S ENOUGH ABOUT THIS ONE.
BUT FOUR, GIVE IT TO THE PEOPLE.
>> I SAID THIS YESTERDAY I JUST
LOVE THE COMMENTS SECTION.
HE SAID I'VE BEEN BETTING THE
DRAYMOND THREE ALL SERIES AND
NOTHING.
JUST SOME GOOD COMMENTS.
BUT TONIGHT IT GETS BETTER.
FOURTH BUT.
YOU AREN'T GOING TO LIKE THIS
ONE.
JORDAN POOLE UNDER 11 1/2 POINTS
AND I'M GOING TO HOLD IT.
>> BLAKE PRESTON IS IN THE CHAT
AND SAYS WHAT ABOUT JORDAN POOLE
OVER 11 1/2 POINTS, SAM?
I DON'T KNOW.
I MIGHT BE SIDING WITH MY MAN
BLAKE, SAM.
>> LET ME EXPLAIN.
HERE'S THE THING.
HE'S SHOOTING THE BALL REALLY
WELL BUT HE HAS BEEN GETTING
HIS MINUTES CUT RECENTLY LIKE
IN DEFENSIVE MATCHUPS.
I THINK HE PLAYED LIKE 17
MINUTES IN THE LAST GAME
BECAUSE STEPHEN KERR IS LIKING
THE PORTER MATCHUPS.
IT'S BEEN AROUND 17, 20 MINUTES
IN THE SERIES.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
HE PLAYED 14 MINUTES IN THE
LAST GAME.
>> YEAH, IF YOU ARE GETTING 14
OR 15 MINUTES, ASKING SOMEONE
AS GOOD OF AN OFFENSIVE SCORER
AS HE IS TO GET 12 POINTS IS A
LOT.
AND I FEEL LIKE AGAIN, HE IS A
GUY WHO I LIKE MORE AT HOME IN
A HOME GAME.
FEEDS OFF THE CROWD, ALL OF
THOSE BUZZER BEATERS AT THE
ENDS OF QUARTERS.
HE FEEDS OFF OF THAT.
ON THE ROAD IN A CLOSE OUT GAME
IN THE FINALS, TO ME THIS FEELS
LIKE A STAFF, KLAY,  DRAYMOND.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO GET
LESS FROM JORDAN POOLE SO IF
HE'S PLAYING  15 MINUTES I
THINK UNDER 11 1/2 IS A GOOD
THAT.
>> SOMEONE IS SAYING I THINK
THE POOLE PARTY IS OVER.
I DON'T THINK SO, JORDAN POOLE
MINUTES ARE IMPORTANT.
THAT'S USUALLY WHEN STEPH OR
KLAY GOES TO THE BENCH, THEY
PUT IN  JORDAN POOLE TO RUN THE
OFFENSE SO THOSE MINUTES ARE
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT AND IF THE
WARRIORS WANT TO WIN I THINK I
NEED TO SEE SOME POINTS SCORED
BY JORDAN POOLE TODAY.
SAM, I THINK YOU GAVE US FOR
FIVE ALREADY.
LET'S GET TO THE NEXT ONE.
LET ME SEE WHAT THE CHAT IS
TALKING ABOUT. HE SAYS I'M
TAKING WARRIORS, IT IS CLOSE
OUT TIME.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
SAM DOESN'T, I DON'T KNOW WHY
BUT I'M WORKING ON THEM.
SAM, YOU HAVE TWO FUTURES.
ARE YOU MAKING MORE MONEY WITH
THE CELTICS?
>> YES.
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN ROOTING
FOR THE CELTICS.
I'LL GIVE YOU MY SIXTH BET TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO GET BACK
ON MY GOOD SIDE.
YEAH, SO I THINK THAT PAYS OUT
AT ABOUT +145.
I WANT THE CELTICS TO WIN, I
WIN MORE MONEY IF THEY DO, BUT
I THINK I SAID THIS THE LAST
TWO SHOWS IF HE GETS TO SEVEN
GAMES THE WARRIORS ARE GOING TO
MANAGE AT HOME.
I THINK WE ARE GETTING A
SEVENTH GAME AND LIKE I SAID.
I ALWAYS SAY I THINK THE
CELTICS ARE THE BETTER TEAM AND
I'VE BEEN ABLE TO SAY THEY
DON'T HAVE STUPID TURNOVERS, IF
THEY DON'T HAVE STUPID
TURNOVERS OR IF THEY DON'T,
LIKE, TOTALLY ABANDON THEIR
OFFENSE.
BUT I HATE TO SAY IT, I'M
REACHING THE POINT WHERE THAT'S
JUST WHO THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE A TON OF SLOPPY
TURNOVERS.
IT'S LIKE, YOU CANNOT JUST SAY,
IT'S WHAT THEY DO.
I TRUST THE WARRIORS IN GAME 7
AND I THINK THE CELTICS GET IT
DONE TONIGHT AT HOME BUT I
THINK THE WARRIORS AND 7 AT
ABOUT +150 IS A GOOD BET AND
THAT'S HOW THE SERIES ENDS.
I THINK THE WARRIORS GET IT
DONE.
>> I'M REALLY NOT GOING TO BE
MAD.
I'M KIND OF GOING TO FEEL SALTY
BECAUSE I WANT THIS TO BE OVER
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE BUT IF IT
DOES GO SEVEN, THE FIRST SHOW
WE HAD FOR THE FINDERS, I SAID
WARRIORS AND 7 SO THAT WOULD
LIKE ME-- MAKE ME LOOK LIKE
YOU, MAKE ME LOOK LIKE A SHARP
A LITTLE BIT.
BUT I WANT TO TRANSITION.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE?
>> I'VE GOT ONE MORE.
SAM, THAT'S ON ME BROTHER.
I WANT THE PEOPLE TO GET THIS
KLAY  BET IN BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THAT GAME SIX HE'S COMING UP
BUT TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
TALK TO ME.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE FOR US?
>> THIS CONFLICTS FOR THE LAST
BET BUT I THINK IT'S A GOOD
VALUE BAT.
I THINK IF THE CELTICS WIN I
REALLY LIKE THIS BET.
IT IS JAYLEN BROWN MVP AT +1800.
JAYSON TATUM HAS NOT BEEN VERY
GOOD IN THIS SERIES.
HE'S SHOOTING LIKE 25% ON TWO
POINTERS SO I THINK IT'S PRETTY
UP IN THE AIR IF THE CELTICS
WIN IT.
JAELYN AROUND +1800.
I THINK JAYLEN BROWN COULD HAVE
A BIG GAME AND GET BACK AND GET
IN THE MIX.
HERE'S MY LARGEST TAKE.
NO ONE ELSE IS BETTABLE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THE NUMBER IS CRAZY
BUT STEPH IS GOING TO WIN AND I
KNOW PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT
ANDREW WIGGINS BEING A
CONTENDER FOR MVP, NO.
IF THE WARRIORS WIN THE SERIES
STEPH IS WINNING IT BUT IT'S
-400 SO I'M LOOKING FOR VALUE
DOWN THE BOARD.
JUST A LITTLE SPRINKLE ON
JAYLEN.
>> LET'S SHOW THE TWEET. I'M
DONE WITH SAM.
JAYLEN BROWN IS AND WINNING
MVP.
WE ARE ROCKING WITH STAFF, EVEN
IF THE WARRIORS LOSE I'M
ROCKING WITH STAFF BUT LOOK.
TRAE YOUNG IS IN THE MIX.
HE GOT A TWEET, I WAS ON
TWITTER SAM EARLIER, AND I SAW
THIS ONE.
IT SAYS YOU GUYS, YOU GUYS CAN
READ IT.
KLAY MAYBE GOING FOR 50
TONIGHT.
HE'S JUST GETTING WARMED UP . I
SAW HIM EARLIER WARMING UP ON
INSTAGRAM FROM 95.7.
THEY WERE SHOWING PLAY KLAY
GETTING READY, NICE AND LOSE.
I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT IT  BUT
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU AND A
QUESTION FOR THE AUDIENCE.
KLAY TOTAL POINTS WAS SITTING
AT 19 1/2 , SITTING AT -120 BUT
I WAS DOUBLING AND DABBLING A
LITTLE BIT MORE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHAT I LIKE TO DO.
I LIKE TO FIND + MONEY.
AND I SAW KLAY , 25 + POINTS
SITTING AT +250 SO MY QUESTION
IS, WHICH ONE OF THESE IS THE
BETTER BET TODAY?
WE ALL KNOW WHAT HE DOES DURING
GAME SIX MATCHUPS.
HE HAS PROVEN TIME AFTER TIME
YEAR AFTER YEAR, AND APPROVED
IN THE PLAYOFFS THIS YEAR WHAT
HE DOES IN GAME SIX SITUATIONS.
I'M PUTTING MY MONEY ON KLAY.
THE QUESTION IS, ARE YOU?
AND WHICH ONE OF THESE SHOULD
BE BET ON?
SHOULD WE TAKE THE REGULAR
POINT TOTAL 19 1/2 SITTING AT
-120, OR SHOULD WE GET A LITTLE
GREEDY?
NOT TOO GREEDY, BUT A LITTLE
GREEDY.
WE KNOW THAT KLAY LIKES TO HIT
THREES SO THIS IS  TWO MORE AND
TAKE THE 25 + POINTS SITTING AT
+250?
>> FIRST, YOU CAN PROBABLY SEE
ME LAUGHING.
THE COMMENTS WHEN YOU BROUGHT
UP TRAE YOUNG EVERYONE IS JUST
FLAMING HIM.
SOMEONE CALLED HIM FRAUD YOUNG,
PEOPLE ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY
FLAMING HIM.
NBA FINALS, HAWKS ELIMINATED,
EVERYONE JUST GOING AFTER TRAE
YOUNG.
>> I'M A LOSER.
SO I WOULD PROBABLY JUST PLAY
IT SAFE AND TAKE THE OVER 19
1/2 AND GET MY BEST CHANCE TO
WIN, NOT GO TO CRAZY WITH THE
+250 BUT THAT'S BECAUSE I'M
LAME AND BORING.
I'M MORE CURIOUS ABOUT THE
AUDIENCE'S TAKE.
>> MY MAN IS TRYING TO PLAY A
CONSERVATIVE?
SAM, HONESTLY I DON'T DISLIKE
IT.
I REALLY WANT TO SPRINKLE BOTH.
SHOULDN'T WE SPRINKLE BOTH?
IF KLAY LANDS ON THE MIDDLE
NUMBER  HE STILL GOT A WIN.
IF HE LANDS ON A HIGHER NUMBER,
WE GOT TWO WINS.
I DON'T KNOW.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
GABRIEL SAYS GAME SIX PLAY
BABY.
AND STUFF COMING OFF OF A BAD
GAME LOCKING IT IN TONIGHT.
I LOVE THAT TYPE OF ENERGY.
SAM, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU LIKE
THAT ENERGY BUT I DO.
SOMEONE SAYS +234 KLAY TO SCORE
25 . EASY MONEY FOR GAME SIX.
I LOVE THE ENERGY IN THESE
COMMENTS.
YOU SAID THERE WAS ENERGY, YOU
SAID COMMENTS ARE ALL OVER THE
PLACE, THEY ARE JUMPING, BUT I
LIKE IT.
I ALSO GOT MONEY LINE KILLER IN
THE COMMENTS SAYING I LOVE KLAY
BUT NOT TODAY . WOW MONEY LINE
KILLER, THAT WAS A CURVEBALL.
I THOUGHT YOU ARE ROCKING WITH
KLAY BUT STILL THOSE ARE ALL
GOOD VIBES . YOU GUYS LET ME
KNOW WHICH WAY YOU ARE GOING.
BUT SAM, I'VE GOT SOME MORE
TWEETS FOR YOU.
LET'S PULL UP TWEET NUMBER ONE.
YOU ARE A BIG SHOT QUALITY GUY.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT THIS
BECAUSE IT'S BASED OFF OF WHAT
YOU LIKE TO PROJECT YOUR BET
SACK ON-- YOUR BETS ON.
YOU TALK ABOUT SHOT QUALITY BUT
YOU GUYS CAN READ.
THERE IT IS.
THE WARRIORS SHOT QUALITY WAS
NOT THE BEST, BUT THEY STILL
WON BY 10 POINTS.
SAM, YOU STILL HAVE THE CELTICS
COVERING TODAY.
I'M LOST.
>> LIKE I SAID.
>> DON'T BE QUIET NOW, YOU HAVE
TO TALK AND SPEAK UP.
YOU LIKE SHOT QUALITY, I
BROUGHT UP SOME STATISTICS
ABOUT SHOT QUALITY AND NOW WHAT?
>> MY INTERNET IS BREAKING UP
GREG.
KNOW I'M JUST KIDDING.
[ LAUGHTER ] LIKE I SAID THE
LAST GAME WAS REALLY
DISAPPOINTING AND SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVED IN THE CELTICS AND WHO
THOUGHT THEY WERE THE BETTER
TEAM.
THE WARRIORS PLAYED A LOT
BETTER, THEY SHOULD HAVE WON BY
MORE POINTS.
NO DENYING THAT.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF TALK AS
THERE ALWAYS WAS BUT THE
WARRIORS WERE JUST A BETTER
TEAM.
I BELIEVE THE CELTICS WILL
BOUNCE BACK AT HOME BUT I STILL
LIKE THEM TO WIN THE SERIES.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU ARE JUST NOT
REFERRING TO SHOT QUALITY WHILE
ANSWERING THE QUESTION.
THAT IS OKAY BECAUSE WE KNOW
YOU ARE A SHOT QUALITY GUY BUT
THAT'S PERFECTLY FINE.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
TALKING POINT.
TWEET NUMBER TWO.
YOU KIND OF MENTIONED THIS, YOU
KIND OF DID.
YOU SAID THE CELTICS DON'T LOSE
THREE GAMES IN A ROW THING.
YOU SEE THE STATISTIC.
CELTICS 3 AND 0 ELIMINATION
GAMES.
THEY TALK ABOUT CLOSE OUT GAMES.
IS THERE GOING TO BE A GAME 7?
THAT'S WHY I CAME INTO THE SHOW
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT I AM
ONE OF THE MOST CONFIDENT
PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES TO BATTING
ON MY BAY AREA TEAM, GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS, 49ers, SAN
FRANCISCO GIANTS.
I WILL DEFEND THEM TO THE THRONE
BUT TODAY, I DON'T KNOW BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S GOING TO GO 7. I'M
SURE YOU THINK THAT IT'S GOING
TO GO 7, RIGHT?
>> I'M JUST GETTING FLAMED IN
THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
PEOPLE ARE JUST LAUGHING ABOUT
HOW STUPID I AM AND HOW YOU
LEFT ME SPEECHLESS AND PEOPLE
ARE RESTING ON THE INTERNET AS
WELL.
SOMEONE SAID I DON'T KNOW WHICH
ONE IS WORSE, SAM'S-- OR HIS
PICKS. GREAT TAKE.
[ LAUGHTER ] BUT TO ME, THE
BIGGER STAT IS THE WARRIORS
BEING 0 AND 3 AND ROAD CLOSE
OUT GAMES.
I THINK THAT'S THE ONE I HAVE
FIXATED ON.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE THIS SUPREME
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY CAN GET
THE JOB DONE AT HOME AND
THEY'VE BEEN RIGHT AT EVERY
SERIES THAT THAT IS CORRECT AND
THEY KIND OF DROPPED THE BALL
ON THESE ROAD CLOSE OUT GAMES
AND I THINK THIS HAPPENS AGAIN
BUT LIKE I SAID.
I THINK THE WARRIORS WILL WHEN
IT AFTER THIS POINT.
>> YOU KNOW BROTHER, I'M
CONFUSED.
I'M SO CONFUSED BECAUSE WE JUST
DID A SEGMENT WHERE YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO GIVE SIX BETS.
YOU GAVE US SIX  BETS,  BUT
THEN I WAS ON YOUR TWITTER
EARLIER AND I SAW YOU TWEET
SOMETHING.
LET ME SHOW THE PEOPLE WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
MY MAN SAM WAS TALKING ABOUT
DRAYMOND GREEN ON TWITTER.
>> THAT'S A GREAT TWEET.
>> BRO YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
DRAYMOND GREEN ON TWITTER BUT
THEN YOU CAME IN HERE AND SAID
JAYLEN BROWN TO WIN MVP.
SAM, ARE YOU OKAY?
I GET HE IS, WHAT IS THAT,
25,000?
BIG ODDS BUT ARE YOU JUST
TWEETING THINGS JUST TO TWEET
THEM?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
YOU HAVE TO TALK TO ME ABOUT
THIS TWEET.
>> I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT ME ADVOCATING FOR
DRAYMOND GREEN TO WIN FINAL
MVPS.
I THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY THAT HIS
NAME IS EVEN ON THE ODDS BOARD
BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN SO OFF AND
IT GOT ME THINKING WHAT IS THE
ACTUAL-- THAT RESULTS IN HIM
WINNING?
AND OF COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT YOU NEED 100 POINTS
TONIGHT TO DO IT.
I THINK THEY'VE SCORED 80, I
DON'T THINK IT'S ENOUGH.
I THINK HE NEEDS THE FULL 100
TO WIN THE MVP.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
>> THAT'S HILARIOUS BUT I WANT
THE PEOPLE TO DECIDE.
YOU LET ME KNOW IN THE
COMMENTS.
IS SAM CONTRADICTING HIMSELF BY
TWEETING THIS AND TELLING US
THAT IT HAS HIM THINKING?
IT MAY BE INTERESTING TO TAKE A
LOOK AT DRAYMOND GREEN, BUT
THEN COMES IN HERE AND DROPS
JAYLEN BROWN IS ONE OF HIS
PICKS.
IS HE CONTRADICT IN?
LET ME KNOW IN THE COMMENTS.
IT HAS BEEN FUN.
WE ARE GOING TO BE BACK HERE, I
BELIEVE WE ARE GOING TO BE BACK
HERE NEXT WEEK IF THEY GO 7. I
DON'T KNOW, MAYBE NOT.
IT HAS BEEN FUN.
SAM, THEY WANT US TO TALK ABOUT
THIS LAST TWEET.
I WAS TRYING TO PASS IT.
I WAS NOT TRYING TO TALK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE CELTICS AND DO THEY HAVE
ANYONE ON THEIR TEAM PLAYING
LIKE A STAR?
>> NO.
I LOVE JAYSON TATUM BUT HE'S
SHOOTING 25% FROM TWO POINT
RANGE AND THAT IS NOT ENOUGH.
I'VE BEEN SUPER DISAPPOINTED.
I THOUGHT MORE OF THIS TEAM AND
I THINK THEY CAN BOUNCE BACK
AND WIN IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY ARE TOTALLY
OUT OF THE SERIES.
I THINK THEY HAVE A CHANCE BUT
IT'S HARD NOT TO LOSE
CONFIDENCE IN THIS GAME RIGHT
NOW.
SAD.
SAD FOR ME.
>> IT IS HARD NOT TO LOSE
CONFIDENCE BUT I AM BACK INTO
THE CHANCE.
HE SAYS I'M A LAKER FAN SO I
WOULD NEVER ROOT FOR A CELTIC,
BUT BOSTON IS FORCING A GAME
SEVEN TONIGHT.
THAT IS BIG. LAKERS FANS SAYING
THE BOSTON CELTICS ARE WINNING
TODAY?
AL HORFORD, OVER 1 1/2 THREES.
IT IS + MONEY.
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT AL
HORFORD?
JAYSON TATUM.
JAYLEN BROWN.
MARCUS SMART.
SAM?
WHY ARE WE TALKING ABOUT AL
HORFORD?
I GOT ONE MORE IN THE CHAT.
GREG WEARING BOSTON GREEN ON
HIS SHIRT?
I'M A COMPANY MAN BRO.
THESE ARE THE NEW BLEACHER
REPORT BETTING SHIRTS.
I'M THE FIRST ONE TO ROCKET BUT
IT CAN BE IN YOUR HANDS REAL,
REAL SOON. MAKE SURE YOU GUYS
CHECK IT OUT.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS, SAM, RYAN
IS IN THE COMMENTS AND THIS IS
GOING TO BE THE LAST ONE.
HE SAYS NO TEAM THAT HAS FORCED
A GAME 6 IN THE NBA FINALS HAS
EVER GOTTEN MORE DISRESPECT. [
LAUGHTER ] I DO THIS TO
EVERYBODY.
I MEAN, LET'S BE HONEST.
YOU GUYS LIKE TO SAY THAT YOU
THINK THE CELTICS ARE THE
BETTER TEAM?
THEY ARE NOT THE BETTER TEAM.
THEY ARE NOT THE BETTER TEAM IN
MY OPINION.
THE WARRIORS HAVE SUPERSTARS,
THEY HAVE MULTIPLE SUPERSTARS
AND MULTIPLE FIRST HALL OF
FAMER'S.
I'M GOING TO STOP IT BECAUSE WE
ARE GOING TO KEEP TALKING ALL
DAY.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS AND KEEP ON
GOING.
ALL DAY, ALL DAY AND ALL DAY.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY, THAT IS
SAM RICHMOND , AND WE ARE OUT
OF HERE.
PIECE.
PEACE.